was this really a good idea
from the Pennsylvania speech the other
night Donald Trump do not touch a baby
holding up this kid his name reportedly
is tristan Murphy he's 18 months and if
we're all lucky he'll still be living
this down in the year 2100 to possibly
using an alias but was anybody else
reminded of an infamous scene in a
presidential movie was it just me I mean
you don't think of this as a
presidential movie it's bloody and
supernatural and their comas and Stephen
King and Christopher Walken yet the dead
zone Martin Sheen playing a presidential
aspirant using the baby as a human field
I'll spare you the rest of the plot I
know I know different intention Don
thinks he's rocky he holding up Simba in
the Lion King not some crazy populist
getting sward it on his path to becoming
the president who starts the nuclear war
the missiles are flying
halleluyah halleluyah I think Trump has
a different intention regardless this
underscores the fact that every week or
so this crazy-ass campaign gives us
another cinematic call back the original
Manchurian Candidate in which James
Gregory should have gotten an Academy
Award as the [ __ ] version of Joe
McCarthy who kept getting told by his
evil wife to change the number of
Communists he claimed were hidden in the
defense department he pleads with her to
just pick one number and she says who
are they writing about all over this
country and what are they saying are
they saying
are there any communists in the Defense
Department of course not they're saying
how many communists are there in the
Defense Department which I pointed out
the other day is what Hillary Clinton
has people doing not are there are any
deplorable --zz among Trump supporters
they're saying how many deplorable ZAR
there among the Trump supporters and of
course there's the awful remake of that
classic film in which if Meryl Streep
ever claims she was not channeling
Hillary Clinton for once she's not being
a good actor many people are saying the
Trump reminds them of
Griffith has lonesome Rhodes in the
immortal a face in the crowd but I don't
really see it Rhodes is a psychopathic
populist snake oil salesman on his way
up from petty criminal but on his way up
to presidential advisor not present
Peter Sellers has chance the gardener in
being there that's invoked a lot there's
something to this Katz is a blank canvas
and everybody else projects their
beliefs onto him
which parallels Trump's appeal you think
he hates who you hate there is one
presidential novel that really matches
parts of Trump's bid to take over the
government it can't happen here by
Sinclair Lewis but nobody has ever had
the stones to make that into a real film
although there was an OK TV pilot in
1968 that ABC ran and then did not make
into a series as Andrew Sullivan pointed
out in May
Trump matches Lewis's character senator
buzz wind ripped wind grip gets the
nomination at a convention in Cleveland
on a populist platform of attacking the
media and warning about non-existent
threats and unrest and by promising
$3,000 cash to every American which he
will pay for because quote we shall have
such a balance of trade Lewis paints
wind rip as vulgar almost illiterate a
public liar easily detected and in his
ideas almost idiotic ok with you so far
when drip is elected by passes Congress
trains his own paramilitary group called
the Minutemen who promptly start
bayonetting protesters and putting
reporters in concentration camps ok but
how big was his junk did when drip
talked a lot about his junk and we keep
hearing the Trump's favorite film is
Citizen Kane which is weird because it's
about the richest man in the country
losing everything including as the
narration goes as independent candidate
for governor the best elements of the
state behind him the White House
seemingly the next easy step in a
lightning political career then suddenly
less than one week before election
defeat shameful ignominious defeat that
setback for twenty years
because of reform in the u.s. forever
canceled political chances with Charles
Foster Kane man if that's the way this
movie ends amen maybe Trump always talks
in the theater or something and he
doesn't know Citizen Kane finishes with
Kane losing in the landslide - and
getting destroyed by the veteran
politician he has repeatedly promised to
send to prison hey wait a minute that's
the closer I'm Keith Olbermann watch
this space
you